sciences bonjour à tous saluent fred
salut patrick bienvenue dans ses stades
science un peu spéciale puisque tout
temps contrepétrie pour ceux qui ne
connaîtraient pas le principe une
contrepèterie qu'est ce que c'est eh
bien il s'agit de renouer avec le jeu
très noble qui consiste à manipuler la
langue française et ses mots afin d'en
décaler les sons on vous laisse un peu
de temps pour la trouver
voilà on a versé l'air c'est bon pour
tout le monde tout le monde l'a
maintenant bord du coup vous aurez
compris que cet épisode n'est pas
forcément tous publics surtout si vous
réussissez à trouver toutes les
contrepèteries pour vous aider on va
afficher à petit compteur de
contrepèteries juste ici et le texte
intégral de cet épisode se trouve dans
la description sicile tandis qu'oman
sont l'évolution de l'homme a eu lieu en
afrique c'est bien normal car comme
chacun sait l'afrique est bonne hôtesse
et nos ancêtres en ont bien profité
c'est là qu'elles sont a permis nos
ancêtres mais avant de les connaître il
a fallu les rôles connaître de cette
question lancinante comment reconnaître
un humain qu'on soit à l'aise avec cette
idée ou non c'est son intelligence qui
permet de distinguer l'humain des autres
animaux même si la bipédie est une de
nos principales caractéristiques
une meilleur moyen de définir l'homme et
qu'au fond il est le seul animal à
pouvoir dire de lui qu'il est humain et
ça faut qu'on encaisse mais devant un
fossile
il faut bien dire qu'on but car cette
définition devient plus compliqué à
appliquer aux baceco présent sur des
hominidés disparu et dont on sait de
surcroît qu'ils avaient à plus petits
savons que le nôtre néanmoins connaître
l'origine de notre espèce celle de nos
sincères géniteur c'est presque vitale
alors les paléontologues se base sur
d'autres caractéristiques pour
reconnaître l'humanité ou non des
fossiles comme la réduction des gamines
visible sur la tête et finalement les
paléontologues sachant bien que l'homme
n'est par essence qu'un singe de boot
table sur la posture en érection de son
dos le premier à présenter ces deux
caractéristiques et toumaï vieux de sept
millions d'années
il ne faut pas confondre toumaï avec
l'uci qui est moins vieille de 4
millions d'années cela veut dire que
tous magne est aussi vieux pour lucie
que lui s'il est pour nous l'époque de
lui si c'était de la science fiction
pour toumaï le chantier de fouilles des
sorties toumaï c'est une équipe de
poitiers qui en a pris la tête dans
l'afrique
toumaï a été découvert dans le désert
tchadien et le moins qu'on puisse dire
c'est qu'il y faisait chaud le tchad
c'est le genre d'endroit où des
canicules s'emballe et il vaut mieux ne
pas traîner en plus de lacoste
heureusement l'équipe était constituée
de paléontologues aguerris quai avant
cela avait mis hors piste dans bien des
fans
vous voyez le genre à avoir fait l'école
des mines de paris toumaï a été l'un des
faux sites clés remettant en question
l'hypothèse de l'origine de l'homme dans
le tiers de l'afrique ne plus à l'est la
fameuse east side story du paléontologue
français il cobas toujours en afrique de
l'ouest - vieux de trois millions
d'années
un autre fossile l'australopithèque
nommé à bell soutient lui aussi
l'hypothèse d'une origine à l'ouest de
l'afrique y ait entre 10 et 10 millions
d'années dans une région encore
couvertes de forêts abreuvés par le lac
tchad lice side story
doit-on encore se laisser abuser par de
tels milk ou bien à cette thèse
mérite-t-elle tous ces braves hoc et
sera difficile dans l'immédiat de
trancher et de faire de nouvelles
découvertes permettant de mettre à
l'épreuve cette belle thèse car
aujourd'hui de courageuse avant dans ces
régions cherchent à bac 5
rigolard entre 4,5 et un million
d'années ont vécu les australopithèques
est la plus connue de leurs
représentants est une femme
c'est la très célèbre lucy elle a été
découverte en ethiopie et là encore les
fouilles n'ont pas été facile il a fallu
monter sur place un camp peu confortable
bien que pas désagréable à la langue
afin que l'équipe dont faisait partie
yves coppens mais dirigée par des
américains puissent orienter fièrement
son job vers des profondeurs zénithale
l'équipe et me tâter la croûte en pierre
en musique se laissant faire les
fouilles au rythme du rock le rock et
plano
c'est pour cela que lucie porte le même
nom que la chanson des beatles lucy in
the sky with diamonds saviez vous que
l'uci est morte relativement jeune vers
l'âge de 20 ans seulement ont des vies
en inspectant le germe de sa dent de
sagesse
si elle avait était vieille ça donne
aurait été visée voire même très émoussé
mais ce n'était pas le cas peut-être
qu'elle est morte en se tordant
l'humérus dit pas n'importe quoi c'est
comme cette légende comme quoi elle
aurait été enceinte c'est du pipeau on
n'a retrouvé aucun squelette dans son
ventre
oui mais enfin le squelette aurait pu
disparaître après tout du cartilage sa
fossilise pas facilement ben alors dans
ce cas pourquoi se contenter d'un seul
mail et pourquoi pas 2 3 des octuplés
pourquoi pas des bébés chats attend
qu'on dit bon admettons
n'empêche que la lutte pour la survie
est sans pitié et lucie a été dépassé
par cette lutte toujours dans l'afrique
de l'est dans la vallée du rift en
tanzanie cette fois a été découverte la
piste de lie to me un véritable fossiles
vivants puisque ses empreintes ont été
laissés par des hominidés vivent enfin
vivant il ya plusieurs millions d'années
évidemment pour savoir quelle espèce a
laissé ses empreintes
il faut pouvoir les dater avec précision
la date fétiche des paléontologues
aurait été que ses empreintes soient du
même âge que lui si c'est certain mais
pour en être sûr il a fallu date et c
qui a été relativement simple puisque
les empreintes ont été faites dans des
cendres et qu'il s'agit d'un matériau de
choix pour la datation au carbone 14 un
an au potassium argon et c'est pas du
ciqi à ses empreintes on a pu le
constater grâce à la datation qui
montrait qu'en fait les empreintes
étaient plus vieille de 400 mille ans
quatre cent mille ans mais c'est long
comme lacunes certes mais le potassium a
abondé nous a laissé aucun choix dans la
date
par contre il nous laisse un large
éventail de possibilités dans l espèce
qui a laissé ses empreintes pas moins de
cinq dont des australopithèques et des
kenyans trope mais quittons un instant
la vallée du rift
car la vraie patrie des
australopithèques ce n'est pas l'afrique
de l'est
mais l'afrique du sud et oui c'est en
afrique du sud que le tout premier
australopithèques a été découvert il ne
s'agit pas de lui si mes de l'enfant de
tendre c'est là bas aussi qu'on a
découvert les squelettes les plus
complets de ces australopithèques comme
australopithecus sediba dans des grottes
reste
en tant cacher ou ont été creusés il ya
presque cent cinquante ans de nombreuses
mines d'or plus ou moins piteuse c'est
bien connu dès qu'on touche à leur banc
les chercheurs d'or brut mais en
visitant les grottes au matin les
paléontologues ont découvert de nombreux
restes d'ossements d'australopithèques
des métatarse à foison c'était un vrai
concert de fossiles est les kops en
plein fou il n'aurait pas fait mieux
tous ces hommes ont été triés les coûts
et les noms et ont été étudiées par la
crème des chercheurs locaux notamment
raymond barthes la plupart des
paléontologues rechignent à farfouiller
dans les milliers de piles de boîtes
toutefois certains paléontologues la de
gratter la marne au burin préfère la
fouille en musique
c'est ainsi qu'une centaine d'années
après la découverte de l'enfant de tongs
et chercheurs sud-africains se sont
rendus compte qu'il possédait depuis
longtemps un fragment de pied
d'australopithèques ils ont alors eu
l'idée saugrenue de prendre leur petit
pied et de retourner dans la mine pour
retrouver à quel bout de tibia il
pouvait s'accrocher et figurez vous qu
après un temps considérable passé à la
mine ils ont fini par découvrir le
squelette d'australopithèque le plus
complet au monde puisse encore que
célibat ou lucie petit pied comme les
dinosaures et et ben oui il faut croire
que la nouvelle génération de
paléontologues a grandi avec ses dessins
animés on n'est pas encore sûr de
l'espèce à laquelle appartient petit
pied il s'agirait peut-être
d'australopithecus prometheus mais rien
de définitif
avis aux amateurs les paléontologues
sont peut-être encore à la recherche
d'une fine appellation pour nommer leur
découverte par assez bien joli tout ces
découvertes mais qu'est ce que nous
apprennent d'autres sur des origines à
part que l'homme est issu d'un ancêtre
commun afrique
en effet tu as raison le travail du
paléontologue ne s'arrête pas une fois
la fuite terminée d'abord on rebouche le
tout est ensuite on met le produit des
fouilles profond dans des caisses où il
va voyager parfois 13 heures debout à
tâter la mer bitume de la route à bord
d'une carriole 100 mules et jusqu'au
musée où l'université où il sera analysé
un quand même bon analysé alors qu'est
ce qu'on trouve il mangé quoi les
australopithèques au juste il était
plutôt salade ou escalope à et bien
justement les paléontologues était
capable de débattre pendant 16 heures
d'affilée
sur ce dernier point avant que n'arrive
enfin les analyses chimiques des autres
qui ont montré une fragmentation des
ressources entre les premiers hommes
pour dire des choses vite et bien que si
australopithèques part entre amp et
homos ont parfois vécu plus ou moins en
même temps et au même endroit
il ne mangeait pas tous la même chose et
de ce fait ces espèces ne s'expliquait
pas mutuellement la chimie isotopique du
constituant un réseau n'est pas la même
selon qu'on soit herbivores carnivores
ou omnivore il se trouve que homo
habilis le plus ancien à volants tendent
à votre ligne et à une chimie osseuse
plus compatibles à l'écart et j'ai une
carnivore contrairement aux
australopithèques qui ont été plutôt agi
par menti les parents trope eux devait
plutôt se nourrir de végétaux comme en
témoigne leur puissante arcade et leurs
hautes crètes sagittale pour l'insertion
de larges muscles mastic ateurs donc
notre ligne et se distingue d'une part
par son régime alimentaire donc aux plus
riches en viande et d'autre part par son
volume cérébral plus grand entre les
australopithèques d'un côté et homo
habilis et l'homo erectus de l'autre le
volume de la boîte crânienne a plus que
doublé au moins bis était un fabricant
d'outils en silex évidemment ah oui le
silex lui plaisent certes oui ils se
mêler chailland couleur partout djiby
fall comme s'il en pleuvait homo erectus
lui à domestiquer le feu entre 1,5
million d'années et 400 mille ans sans
doute parce qu'il aimait s'extasier le
soir devant un feu de poutres il est
aussi le premier à quitter l'afrique
natale partant vers le nord-est
jusqu'aux portes de l'eure est là une
branche divergentes domo mon touch v2
nos routes plein d'embûches
ces exilés de l'homme de pékin et
l'homme de géorgie dans un premier temps
en asie de très nombreuses concessions
de fouilles auront été prises à des fins
de prospection dans les sites à homo
erectus
ces recherches ont habillé les sites
très riche de made man ici en géorgie
certains crânes montrant une grande
variabilité morphologiques pourrait bien
bouleverser ce que nous croyons savoir
de l'évolution de notre famille une
autre découverte révolutionnaire a été
celle de l'homme de florès certains
prétendent que l'homme de flores était
un individu malade microcéphale au même
trio mik
mais d'autres trouve révoltant pour le
diffamant délation ces derniers pensent
arguments à l'appui qu'il s'agirait en
fait d'un descendant d'homo erectus
atteint de nanisme qui n'est non pas
vieux de plus
millions d'années mais de seulement 18
mille ans il a vécu en indonésie à la
même époque cro magnon ses ancêtres ont
dû arriver là à pied par la chine en
profitant d'une baisse du niveau de la
mer ils ont dû être pris d'une étrange
pas leur en quittant le banc du coup
vous aurez compris que aux invectives
c'est un peu le bazar on simonis même
parfois avec des prêts néandertaliens
avec homo rudolf unisys et homo ergaster
cette fois de possibles cousin de
l'homme moderne
c'est vous dire mais ce dont on est sûr
c'est qu'au milieu de tout ça n est
l'homme de cro magnon la terreur des
carrières nash ancêtre direct de l'homme
moderne et non notre ancêtre ce n'est
pas née andersen
d'ailleurs c'est une histoire
franchement compliqué car l'adn de homo
antecessor qu'on croyait proche de
néandertal est en fait proche de celui
de l'homme de denisova qui ne reste
aujourd'hui connue que par pour ainsi
dire presque rien du tout comme quoi
études et les eaux c'est bien mais
étudié les gènes c'est capital c'est sûr
car à l'instar de schiste célèbres comme
le schiste de burgès les découvertes
permise par la génétique apporte un
horrifique bénéfices à la recherche sur
le plan des découvertes mais aussi sur
le plan financier
et oui car afin de banque et à la vue
d'un donc il faut séduire les mécènes et
l'adn et les nouvelles technologies cède
pas mal pour que enfin finissent par des
coulées des fonds substantiels
je stoppe tout s'est terminé merci de
l'avoir suivi nous espérons vous avoir
appris plein de choses
au moins des contrepèteries et vous
avoir diverti sur ce merci à tous et bon
courage polyphonique